So for all the same reasons,
every time the interpreter visits the middle line of the carlike decorator,
a new function will be generated as that car's .move method.
Depending on how many cars we make, this could take up a lot of memory.
But there's a slight advantage to putting the .move method inside the body of
the carlike decorator function.
Now that the .move function is being created every time,
each one has access to a unique closure scope created when we invoke
the carlike function, thus, we don't need to rely on the keyword, this, anymore.
So refactor this code for me.
Try to make it work such that the move method does not even refer to
the parameter, this.
It accomplishes all the same thing but without using the keyword, this.